quelle époque de singles et vous eve et
vous aime et vous vous souvenez du coc
vide
j'arrête de vous parler peut-être
c'est le stand peur paranoïaque vous
rigolez deux mois
sept en train de rigoler de moi
j'avais une vanne mais je les ai perdus
dans mon pantalon
vous êtes là
elle cohabite cymbales le confinement
vous vous rappelez du premier
confinement combien eu un deuxième
confinement ja le 2è l'ol 2e confinement
il a été moins bien respectés qu'un prof
de techno et
à personne et le calcul et le deuxième
confinement et fuck you le deuxième
conflit
photo archives
l premier confinement vous rappeler
comment on a agressé intellectuellement
vous rappelez l'ont fait les gens
civilisés pouvoir d'achat place de ce
fait et vous rappeler comment on arrive
et on se
[Musique]
fait pendant le premier confinement se
signer des autorisations de sortie de
nous mêmes pour nous même à nous mêmes
trapel débat je soussigné moi même c'est
bien moi peut-être moi qui suis moi
c'est moi